all right now to some mysteries of the  unknown where's the music again I know  it's dude dude those Encounters of the  Third Kind for those of you of a certain  age for the first time the Navy is  acknowledging the existence of what it  calls unidentified aerial phenomena it  used to be called UFO in 2017 and 2018  the New York Times in an organization  called to the Stars Academy of Arts and  Sciences released three videos they  showed Navy fighter jets encountering  mysterious objects in the sky one video  captures a pilot speculating what those  objects are take a look so the  mysterious objects moved at hypersonic  speeds with no wings no engines or  visible signs of propulsion the Navy  admits it cannot identify what they are  it's like a big old bumblebee I love  this name the Navy wants us to use  unidentified aerial phenomenon you ap is  just not catchy like UFO now we want to  believe that  all right glad thanks